hey welcome to the Reuben report I'm
Dave Rubin I hope you know that already
we have a big show for you this week to
all star celebrity panelists first up
you know this guy from a little band
known as in sync he also is now the host
of the pop 10 on Sirius XM outq my old
stomping grounds Lance Bass how you
doing I'm doing good how are you doing
good doing good and next up we have a
man that you know we are produced here
by The Young Turks this is the original
Young Turk so I assume you know who he
is
JQ ger how are you sir awesome I feel
good about this
ya know I feel great about it I'm just
shocked it I thought for sure was
Backstreet Boys know who's insane
reasons yes okay I get confused myself
okay all right 98 degrees marathon yeah
I always google with myself like yeah
wasn't it sync yeah yeah it was in sync
and we're in sync so all right let's get
right to it it was a big week for the
gays every week that we've done this
show something happens to the gays and
actually it's been pretty good for the
last couple months we got our first out
gay professional athlete this time it
was a that was give me a better whoo
whoo okay sure yeah whoo
thus the difference between gay people
and straight people God was Jason
Collins of the NBA 12-year veteran a
free agent right now so he's not signed
with the team at the moment but he is an
active player he came out of the closet
in an article penned in Sports
Illustrated magazine and this is this is
pretty great so there's a lot of things
I want to talk about with this first
though Lance I am sure you've never been
asked this question before but you're
sort of the you're sort of the poster
child for the big coming-out People
magazine I think was around demo now the
the push a child for coming out you you
did it it was on the cover of People it
was a huge thing maybe we've gone from
that in 2006 I think this might be the
beginning of the
and of the big coming housement I mean I
I mean I really do back then it was a
little different for sure you know not
many people were coming out my situation
was a little different from Jason's I
had 24 hours to decide if I was going to
do this article or not because the
magazines were gonna write it anyway
I was already out of course to my
friends and family and I already was in
relationship so to me my personal life I
was out but I guess publicly they needed
that yes I am that confirmation so I had
24 hours decide if I was gonna be on the
cover of People magazine yeah and do the
story with them and of course I said yes
okay I want to get my story out and
within 48 hours it was outs and I didn't
know what to expect at all and you've
never looked back and it's been pretty
good since yeah you rip the band-aid off
and you know it's amazing yeah I was
back then it was scary because one thing
I didn't want the gay community to be
embarrassed by me coming out I didn't
want everyone to make it a joke and be
like yeah that boyband guy of course
he's gay but the way they handled it was
amazing I was expecting the lintels of
the world to really just give it to me
but they it was the first time I heard
people say who cares anymore like really
like who cares and that was kind of a
nice change for me yeah which all we
really want is for people to say well
who cares that Jake when did you come
out as straight yeah fairly early on but
you know it didn't stick like
unfortunately the girls didn't get the
memo yeah like I'm like no I'm sure
they're like yeah but I still don't care
they just see no I do not care all right
so let's talk about the news angle of
this whole thing because obviously this
was the story of the week you know for a
month we've been talking about North
Korea then two weeks of Boston and then
suddenly it all disappeared today
because of come out is it really that
big really so I think it's big because
it's the first player in any of the four
major sports so that's a watershed
moment anytime there's a moment like
that it's huge news that's why
everybody's talking about it uh but on
the other hand I would lessen that in
the sense that we've I think gotten to a
point where we're like whatevs you know
and that's a great place to be and so I
mean like think about right now
Oh a black player joined the NBA okay
that's not a new story right but back in
the day there was a giant news story so
hopefully we're soon coming to a day
when okay a musician or a basketball
player or whatever is gay
whatever yes do you guys think everyone
keeps saying well that sports is the
last bastion where you it's okay to be
anti-gay and you know there's the locker
room and it brings up just other issue
in FreeStore probably the next thing
yeah that's the what's the most out
that's the next hurdle enough to get
over exactly yeah there's one more layer
though the Pope's post yes gay Pope at
leats Pope's that was the real martyr
one that was gonna mural actually he
used to be gay Pope's you know that yeah
yeah it's a long history of popes and
like half the time it did be gay and it
like you know Leviticus don't worry
about that I mean we all eat shrimp
anyway right right and then the next
Pope would come my book oh that's
ridiculous no no we're back to an T yet
doesn't the Pope own like the biggest
gay bathhouse in Europe or something
isn't it on the street some are a lot of
the Cardinals live there in Italy like
literally the biggest bathhouse in
Europe they just coincidentally live
upstairs but they don't know anything
okay wait let's not get let's not go
correction that can only take us to a
bad place in fact I do think though that
there is one other place where coming
out still would be frowned upon and I
think it's from the world you came from
the boy band situation that we're yes I
do think it's weird I mean if you took
one of these One Direction kids because
they basically are kids
my guess is one of them is gay well I
mean statistically speaking one you know
one probably is yeah but it's crazy with
a market like that because 100% young
women and they fantasize about these
guys and then you have the record labels
and everyone kind of grooming you to
make sure that you don't even mention
you have a girlfriend so screw the fact
that you're gonna you know come out as
being gay it runs their own business
plan right how ironic is that actually
they're telling you don't even say you
have a girlfriend cuz we don't have two
years much less that you might be gay
because it helps a little bit right you
don't have a girlfriend but these girls
really do fantasize it's a crazy thing
had a girl a couple months ago come up
to me and she thought that we were in
love and that it was that she was
waiting for me this whole entire time
and she thought the whole gay thing was
just a joke basically I was just lying
about it was it Miley Cyrus damn it cuz
she bought me it is Miley yeah desperate
for attention well so I'm fascinating
way that I want to ask you a couple
questions right so your record companies
you are not gonna tell them back when in
sync was super hot no way oh yeah I
wouldn't tell the guys you kidding me
well I felt a responsibility I really
did I felt like I had for my best
friend's careers in my hands I know it
was different time it was you know early
2000s and I felt that if anyone found
out that it would be the end of the
group everyone would completely make fun
of us and we would no longer make music
anymore which might have happened I
don't know so you had to hide it from
everybody everyone I even hid it for
myself I didn't have any relationships
as long as I was with in sync I was
completely asexual the closet is a very
small room that you can turn into a
giant imaginary world I want to remind
you guys that the official outfitter of
the Rubin report is bonobos go to
bonobos com use code TRR to zero and get
yourself this fancy shirt